but look what happened with Co from on
high they handed down send yeah make
them go home send them home tell them to
come back when they po2 is 80 that was
astonishing to me what do you mean they
sent people home without care a lot was
it wasn't that not because they were
overwhelmed it was they didn't want to
become overwhelmed they didn't want to
become infected and they were told from
on high what to do rather than what they
wanted to do and they just did it they
just complied can I ask you then do you
believe in socialized medicine or a two
tier system what do you think the fix is
I think I think the fix is a tier system
of some type because people are always
going to want to be able to go to the
market and get whatever they need if
they can afford it they just want to do
that but if you you there's got to be
some other way of doing this in the way
we're doing one of the things to make
insurance is like a um utility where
they just are regulated completely and
can't do what they want to do as a
business because as a business their
priorities are messed up the same as the
Pharma Pharma business well Pharma yeah
Pharma you know the the relationship
between the regulators and the
pharmaceutical I didn't know I co
exposed so much for me a naive me I'm
just practicing medison I don't think
about it I didn't know so many of us
were employees I didn't know that all
the FDA officials go on to be
pharmaceutical Executives and vice versa
and the CDC and they go back and forth
it's wild that relationship it is it is
so adulterated you've been very vocal
about your opinion on the way we handled
covid from like being very staunch one
way to issuing an apology and then
you're still being very vocal about how
we handled it and all that stuff so how
do you feel now about covid I know
before you were very I my
my the reason I apologize is because my
family started getting de death threats
and I'm happy to apologize if I got
something wrong and I'm sure I got some
stuff wrong and so I apologize for it
but when you look back I got just about
everything right it turned out but
people said I was WR so you're resending
the AP no I'm happy to apologize don't
get family in trouble okay I'm not I'm
not I'm I have I don't said I AP I was
hubristic I was over my skis I was
trying to make a point which was my
point was and I overstated it I started
I I made a bunch of errors and I
apologize for that but what I my point
was at the time was we just had a
pandemic are you aware that we had a
pandemic just before Co are you aware no
no nobody was aware what was the
pandemic H1N1 and it killed 300,000
people and you don't even know it
happened and we had a pandemic and my
point was yes this one is going to be
bad it's going to be worse but isn't
there I mean do we have to go from
nothing to complete disaster I there
seems like there was an intermediate
Zone and I but here's what I will I'll
ask you as a lay I want to hear what
just you know at the end of every of
those statements what I kept saying was
please just Len listen to the CDC listen
to Dr fouchy they will get us through
this just calm down stop this don't
listen to The Press don't listen to the
New York Times listen to those guys now
they got all
panicky too I didn't know they were
going to get quite over their skis the
way they did but I worked I was deep in
the AIDS epidemic I was deep in that
that's why I got involved in radio is
because of AIDS right and I fou you was
my hero my entire career my entire
career that's all you were saying I'm
sorry no I didn't want to stop you I'm
sorry if I if I interrupted what I was
saying was science yeah is an evolution
procedure and continues to be an
evolution what you so what I found
fascinating and scary was whether it was
fouchy you anybody who had a microphone
or had a soap box when they said this is
what needs to be done yeah first of all
the Uproar for whatever needs to be done
is not worthy of an uproar and when that
changes it's not you're wrong it's we
learned more we you know nobody's
getting that uproarious when you hear
you know
coffee's bad for you coffee's good for
you you shouldn't have wine now we can
have wine now you you know when it and
the truth of the matter is that
Co maybe for the average healthy young
person without any uh mitigating you
know yeah underlying you
know they were possibly okay the flu
kills a lot of people H1N1 kills a lot
of people but this was you know in in
the in the rest homes and things like
that it was killing people like crazy
and I think what people forgot was it's
not only about you and we don't we don't
think about us and my biggest fear on
covid was not that I would die not that
I that I would give it to somebody that
would die and I don't want to be the one
that gives you that that passes that
along so I don't know why everybody got
so angry and political and well the the
part that lingering is the part where
the people that had an
opinion not just crushed alternative
opinions but destroyed people's lives I
know
extremely
decorated academics and professors that
lost their jobs have destroyed their
lives because they raised their hand and
said I I'm not sure is the way there
might be a better way to do this that's
all they said I think we have a better
way to do this let's really focus on the
Elder people let's think about you know
then no you're you're you're destroyed
and those people are pissed now they
still remain pissed because they were
really that was a miscarriage of U did
you have an opinion that has
changed uh my opinion changed all the
time yeah for sure just like you're
saying it changed all the time uh I um I
I'm let's see how would it have changed
I probably was more concerned about
young people in Co than I should have
been uh given the data I vaccinated
everybody aggressively um I I had an
opinion about the way we rolled the
vaccine out I think that was kind of odd
and weird and particularly in California
didn't make sense and it did not
specifically service the people at risk
uh and well didn't didn't they roll it
out where the older people were first we
I remember we not really it was sort of
more communities at risk and it wasn't
clear what that should be and who and it
was almost hospital by hospital had
different policies it was very weird and
and frankly the hospital I was involved
with just did a terrible job and I was
running around trying to get the vaccine
and I got covid trying to get the
vaccine and any event the and I was
taking care of covid patients and this
group that we were trying to protect uh
the other thing is you know I still I
vaccinate my elderly patients and I
boost them I and I'm the benefit is
clear to me it's absolutely clear that
we have really we did something
extraordinary in terms of protecting the
atrisk population if I'm 25 years old
though the risk of Co now is is zero
it's
0.00000000 maybe one risk of myocarditis
is one800 or maybe one let's say one in
5,000 just to be conservative that's the
risk reward isn't there so I don't
understand the excesses we're getting
into